because we've been so programmed to  devalue ourselves and deep you know  disempower  ourselves that we look at ourselves as  victims and frail uh biological entities  you know ripe for bacteria to eat us up  and all these other things it's like  this is totally untrue  so the issue is we have to start from  that belief and change these beliefs of  who we are we are profoundly powerful  people  look you can walk across hot coals you  know  a woman can lift a car off of an infant  without thinking about it  down south the  baptist fundamentalists of the  pentecostal faith work themselves up in  a jesus state and drink strychnine in  toxic doses to demonstrate that god  protects them they're not harmed by the  strychnine i mean you can walk across  fire you can drink poison you can lift  thousands of pounds  where's the frail image come from and  that's a belief